et le groupe indochine qui vient qui va
partir en tournée à travers la france
venez vous asseoir dans le groupe
indochine on est quatre mais il n'y en a
qu'un qui parle
voilà c'est celui qu'on a choisi alors
nicole cornu langlois en deux mots on
peut être représentée ce groupe que bien
sûr tout le monde connaît oui alors ce
groupe a eu le prix rock 83 il vient
d'avoir les trophées du midem et il a eu
le disque d'or pour le disque
l'aventurier ça veut dire plus d'un
million donc d'acheteurs et se disent
que l'aventurier et effet d'après la
bande dessinée de bob morane c'est ça et
c'est en grande partie ce qui a fait son
succès bah oui en fait en grande partie
oui c'est arrivé un naissant aventure
est tous des prêts l'impression vous
n'êtes pas les seuls à vous inspirer les
bandes dessinées gotainer par exemple
conçoit son spectacle comme autant de
séquences de bande dessinée ça inspire
beaucoup les groupes aujourd'hui
bah oui surtout que maintenant on n'a
plus besoin de s'évader un peu je veux
dire nous c'est la lecture de maintenant
je veux dire les jeunes maintenant lisez
la bande dessinée pas des bouquins donc
ça se remet sur les paroles et ça ça se
sent dans les uns dans les paroles des
chansons
je dois aller vite dans la mise en scène
depuis quelques temps vous avez commencé
sous le nom d'indochine
vous aviez des tendances côté asiatique
pourquoi benoît indochine c'est aussi
français je veux dire c'est une tendance
à l'évasion avant tout je ne sais pas
une tendance ni provocatrice ni ni
aventureux c'est une qui a tendance à
s'évader à retrouver leur est de
l'exotisme ou en faillite vous été très
influencé par les nazis pendant
longtemps
ouais d'amuser maintenant la musique
chinoise wei un peu les sonorités je
lève tout les tous les petits tambours
un chinois les clochettes chinoise et
tout ça à vous partez en tournée il a en
province et vous avez une spécialité
sont vraiment les jeunes vous voulez
toucher les jeunes de 10 à 14 ans donc
vous avez une formule qui permet de
faire venir les jeunes vous pouvez nous
en parler
non c'est à dire qu'on s'est rendu
compte l'an dernier on a tourné un peu
dans toute la france et que ont passé
dans des clubs de rock ces clubs
d'europe sont plus ou moins interdits
aux moins de 18 ans en france et ont
passé vers minuit on s'est aperçu qu'on
avait reçu pas mal de l'aide de très
jeunes qui pouvaient pas aller nous voir
donc là on a décidé au pas dans toute la
france on fait des concerts à huit
heures du soir dans des salles dans les
centres villes
pour que les plus jeunes puissent bien
devenir nos voiles mais cette tournée
commence quand c'est ça on part demain
et puis on termine fin mars bien ballon
peut-être les écouter chanter après tout
très page pour que ce serait le plus
simple vision que on annonce qu'il parte
en tournée le groupe indochine qu'on va
entendre tout de suite dans un dernier
clip vidéo comme il est con